I would say, be in the world.
Invest in your network.
Read relentlessly.
If someone asks you to do something,
try and say yes.
Which is why I'm here.
And it drives my PA completely mad
because I do try to do a lot of this
because you never know.
[--].
You never know.
And the second one,
which gets me into a lot of trouble
is what's the worst
that can happen. Right?
Debbie Wosskow,
thank you so much for joining me.
How are you today?
Yeah, I'm fine, thank you.
Thanks for having me,
from London.
It's dark and cold here.
I love it.
It's dark and not very cold in Tel Aviv.
It's actually quite nice here
in the middle of winter.
But it's great to have you here.
I can't wait to talk
about the sharing economy,
which I know has been
a topic of passion of yours
for quite some time.
But you've had some really
incredible experiences
with Love Home Swap,
which you sold in 2017.
And then, with your most recent company,
that you've started now with AllBright
from 2018, in the past two years
talking about
the professional network for women.
So, a lot to talk about.
But before all of that
I have to learn about what it's like
to get married
during quarantine and covid.
Yeah.
So, I had a locked on wedding in London.
And I had that on about
the last day that it was possible
to have a wedding
and it was small but perfectly formed.
But actually,
so much love in the room.
And I think for the people
who were there,
it was one of the first times
that they had been out
or seeing each other.
But the main thing was
that was my second marriage.
And I have two children
from my first marriage.
And my husband has a child
from his first marriage
and really it was their day.
So, it was a big party for them.
But just a real highlight
and a tough year that we've all had.
We will always remember 2020
for good reasons
as well as difficult reasons.
I love that.
That's very inspiring.
Debbie, tell me a little bit
about your journey.
Because it's a really interesting journey
looking from the side.
And then I'd love to transition
to hearing a little bit more specifically
about your ventures
and about the Sharing Economy.
But take me all the way back to Oxford.
How do you get started
with your entrepreneurial self?
And what are some of the things
that are guiding you
as you're making your decisions
to start these organizations?
You know, it's very hard to see
the narrative in a life
that's being lived
and going forwards.
But I think when you have some time
to reflect on your why,
I'm from a family of entrepreneurs.
They wouldn't class themselves
as entrepreneurs
so, that's quite a fancy word,
that of a business owners
to self starters,
a Jewish immigrant family to the UK.
I'm third generation.
And I grew up around people
who work for themselves.
I didn't know anybody
in my extended family
who had a conventional job.
In particular,
the women in my family,
my mother and my grandmother
who I was very close to
who died aged 97 a few years ago
were strong, tenacious women
who control their own destiny,
who ran businesses
and were matriarchs.
And that's very much, I suppose,
the role model that I was very used to.
And in that standpoint
two things are quite important.
I think everybody talks
about work and business
around the kitchen table.
And I'm very aware of that
with my own children.
That it was very normal
to talk about work.
I spent a lot of my formative years
driving around with my grandma
in her armored vehicle
which she never learnt how to reverse.
That's one thing we have in common.
Being terrible drivers.
Dropping money off the bank
and, you know,
it's what you see.
So, I think some of it is
you have to see it
to be a particular as the woman.
The second thing is that
academic excellence is non-negotiable
and that, you know,
you have to work hard at school
and be a be a good student.
So, I think those two things
are very formative.
But I do think,
I set up my first business at 25,
so, 21 years ago
and I think that the risks things
if it's normalized to be part
of an entrepreneurial
self starting community
did not feel risky.
And if I look at my siblings,
I'm from a big family, one of five,
everybody works for themselves.
I actually I worked with my brother
the next one, that one,
he was with the same college as me.
I've worked with him
for over a decade now.
My middle sister is a psychotherapist,
but she runs her own practice.
And she runs buildings.
I think so much of it
is on the nature nurture
debate around
normalization perhaps,
is a bit in the genes.
But I think it just felt like
what you did.
And I think for women,
if I link that to my career
and my business now, AllBright,
I think positive female role models
who take risks and show that
it's possible to start businesses
in your 30s,
which is the main age
to start a business
which is often when women
are having children,
I think really does make you see
the art of the possible.
And I think that's been
a big part of it for me.
I love that.
Talk to me a little bit
about the Love Home Swap.
So, home exchange.
What even is that?
And how do you then get into
being in the home swapping market?
You know, I think,
you get different types of entrepreneurs.
I'm quite simple in many ways
and that I can only start
and feel passionate about businesses
that I can relate to
and to some extent,
why I am the ultimate consumer.
That's not everybody's journey but mine.
So, all of my businesses
have come from a position
of need or personal connection.
And then of home swap story
and this is the real story,
not just a [--] is that
I went on holiday
when my children were tiny,
three months and two.
And the people who have young children
who were listening,
parent's holiday is a pretty miserable.
You know, you sit in a hotel room
with the lights off.
Watching a movie with the sound off,
eating room service,
and you're feeding one another.
And they're expensive
and they're not a life lived well.
And on the flight on the way back
from this holiday,
I watched the movie, The Holiday,
which I actually re-watched
this Christmas
and that's what hold up.
Which for those of you
who haven't seen it,
Cameron Diaz swapped homes
with Kate Winslet.
And it made me think,
A, inspiration can strike at any time.
You have to have eyes and ears open
and be in the world,
is what I was saying.
Right.
Yes, I think it's really important
because that's where
it always comes from for me.
But, B, made me think,
does that even exist?
Because actually,
the holiday that I wish I just had
was to stay in a home, not a hotel.
To swap, frankly,
at that time in my life
with someone else's.
Right.
And I think particularly
with small children,
to be in somewhere that
was more spacious in a community.
And this was at the very early days
of Airbnb.
So, the sharing economy,
which I later became
I suppose the sort of queen of in the UK,
I authored the Wosskow Report
to advise the UK government
on how to regulate the sharing economy.
I was the chair sharing economy UK.
So, that sense of making more
of the assets that you own
and the skills that you have
was a big part of my life
for about five years.
But at this stage, nobody,
nobody was thinking
about it in that way.
But I think there was the sense in which
we needed to make our assets sweat harder.
And we needed to think about,
perhaps, living life a bit differently.
So, the inspiration was the movie.
I suppose then the test is well,
what do you do about it?
And I think what entrepreneurs
often have in common is
they need an itch to scratch.
They are very relentless.
They don't let something draw up.
The test for me is always
if it gives me goose bumps
or am I still.
So, I just kept all night.
I could sort of see the market.
And then you know,
I was management consultant
from a million years ago.
So, I think you always then get to
to analyze an opportunity
and product market fit.
I think it's always a combination
of analytics and instinct for me.
Because my business is a B2C businesses.
So, you've got to be able
to get something up and running.
Consumer test it pretty quickly
to check it's the thing.
I suppose that sort of tipping point
was my brother Ben.
He was about to go into an MBA,
and I dissuaded him from doing that.
And I said, "I have this idea,
why don't you come
and do it with me.
It's for six months. I'll salary you
as my impoverished little brother."
And I'd already have one
and that's my marketing services business.
And that was it.
So, I looked at from the outside,
these things look super easy.
In equal measure, it was hard,
riddled with mistakes,
exhausting, boring.
Can you give me an example
of a mistake that you made
that in hindsight you're saying?
I think it takes, this would be
if I'm to give any advice
to people listening,
to really find your sweet spot
on product market and pricing fit
just takes quite a long time, right?
You don't just
maybe some people do,
but I never do.
So, you're always tweaking it.
What if it is?
And what if it's that?
And you test this, you know.
And we went on a few blind alleys,
I think.
The aha moment for Love Home Swap
was around what became known
as the three-way swap.
In other words,
I say for at least the first year
of the business,
we'd waste a little bit of capital.
I funded it.
We were, you know,
there was a thing.
But you could, if I'm in London
and you're in Tel Aviv,
we could only swap with one another.
I think it's really freeing up
and developing the algo
that enabled London
to swap with Tel Aviv
to swap with Paris.
That then meant that
this would be a 365 day a year.
You could bank credit.
And then I think,
that was inflection point one.
Inflection point two was realizing,
and this is why being in the world
is really important,
it was a bit like a modern day Timeshare.
Right.
You were essentially banking time
in your home as a tradable asset
to trade [--].
And that was sort of a moment,
because I didn't know
the Timeshare industry.
But then I, and I think
this is another point around commitment
and total immersion,
I really got to know
the Timeshare industry.
I went to all the Timeshare conferences.
I was in the room.
And what happened then
and I'm a great believer
in organized serendipity,
which is partly when we [--]
which I think is really important.
I spoke at the European
Timeshare Conference
on why I thought Home Swapping
was the future of Timeshare.
And I met someone from Wyndham,
the hotel group who owned RCI,
the Timeshare business.
And that was the exit. Right?
And I think, there's a real question mark
I think around
during the pandemic, networks,
in particular, networks for women.
And that's always been a big passion
that women's networks
are not as good as men.
And networks
are how you get shit done, right?
Without networks,
I didn't sell that business.
Without realizing,
"Okay, hang on.
I think it's this,
but actually it's this."
So, I would say be in the world.
Invest in your network.
Read relentlessly.
If someone asks you to do something
try and say yes.
Which is why I'm here.
And it drives my PA completely mad
because I do try to do lot of this.
because you never know.
You know, [--].
You never know.
And the second one
which gets me into a lot of trouble
is what's the worst
that can happen. Right?
Right.
So, between those two things,
you have to put yourself out there.
And that was Love Home Swap.
Beginning to end, five years, exit.
But honestly, there were so many moments
where that could not have happened
unless you were in the room
and you're always trying
to frame or reframe
what your business is.
And you're not don't be,
be passionately committed to the mission.
Right.
Don't be 100% without openness
committed to the original concept.
Because it will change.
It will just change, you know,
and you have to change with that.
I love that.
The commitment to the mission,
but also a commitment to being able
to change the concept of how you execute.
There's no weakness in that
in the execution.
You know, we pivot, I mean
I don't even think that as a pivot.
It's just life, right?
We're always doing that
to try and and change up.
And I don't mean to sound trite
and I don't want to sound trite
when commenting on last year,
but if life gives you lemons,
you've got to make lemonade. Right?
And, you know,
I think that
there's been a huge opportunity
in the pandemic
for businesses to really think about
how does their mission support people
within the pandemic.
Right.
What do consumers want.
What do they need.
How can we best service them.
And I think,
I've watched people around me
or businesses,
because I'm a serial angel investor.
And in the AllBright
we run off female founders pitch series.
So we have four women pitching
on two occasions a month.
Every single month,
we see a lot of entrepreneurs.
And my advice would be,
you've got to roll with that.
And I think a surprising amount
of people don't
and you do have to.
I just love that.
And I have to say
that I completely agree.
This whole show came about in March,
the rather the peak
of the first week of the pandemic.
And I couldn't get into the Ubers
and meet interesting people
in the Valley.
So, I started meeting them
on Zoom, and at the end,
it was beautiful because
I believe this is episode about 300
or something that we're recording.
And just it's through a lemonade
that's coming out of this.
And I'm so thankful for people like you
that are willing to come on the show
and share their experience and insights.
Debbie, tell me a little bit about
the sharing economy
and then I'd love to move towards
talking about AllBright
and the amazing work
that you're doing there
for networking with women.
You know,
I suppose my final point
on the sharing economy
and people have the stomach for it,
you know, I wrote like a 100,000 words
on this thing so you can go and read them.
With huge opportunity
comes masses of responsibility.
That's life, right?
So, what was the opportunity
that because of digital platforms,
digital payment platforms,
that's been the big game changer
for the sharing economy.
Businesses like, starts with paper
but stripe, that mean that
I can set up a platform
and take money in real time,
anyone, anywhere without going
into too much detail.
When we first started Love Home Swap
you couldn't do that.
Right?
So, we were having like banking accounts
with money on escrow,
30 day payment.
You know, not possible.
Everything's changed over a decade.
Comes huge responsibility.
And as ever, you know,
I'm a philosophy graduate,
so, I like big questions.
Some existential questions,
what does it mean to be employed?
How should people work?
What is the future of work look like?
What are the responsibilities
of platforms?
What does it mean
to be self-employed?
What's the responsibility of the state?
You know, it's like really big stuff.
And I think it's the most seismic shift
of the last 50 years.
And it has been exacerbated
by the pandemic.
We can work differently.
We have to work differently. Right?
It's a huge opportunity.
It's an absolute radical shift
in the world of work.
And it has the potential
to create massive problems
around ethics welfare
and the way that we look after people.
So, you know, it's not an easy one.
But I like that kind of thing
because I think that the more people,
not just with theoretical brains
but with practical experience,
you can try and think around
those challenges the better.
And I think that the relationship
between policy making
and real life entrepreneurial
and front line
business experience matters.
And which is why
I always have something
like that in the go the moment
I'm on the mayor
of London's business board.
I think that
we should have a voice.
We've got a response
but we can't complain
about the laws that are made
across the world
if we're not standing up
and being counted.
So, I always like to stand up
and be counted.
I just love that.
And in just a few words,
a little bit about AllBright,
and why you're spending
your time now working
with this professional network.
So look, I guess
again with this
sort of benefit of hindsight
sweep of history thing,
I'm so used to being
the only woman in the room
that I didn't even notice anymore, right?
You're woman who raises capital
then you are so in the minority,
you know,
two percent of capital goes
to back a female founder.
Seven percent of investors are female.
Two percent of partner level.
One in six in leadership positions
in corporates.
The stats for backing female founders
are going down.
The pandemic has made it work.
You know, like come on.
So, I think to this point on serendipity
and being in the world,
there have been different points
in my life that change your life,
different people that you meet
that change your life,
that you have to be open to.
And I met Anna Jones,
she's my co-founder in AllBright,
at a party four years ago.
A party I nearly didn't go to.
And she was the CEO of Hearst,
the publishing magazines business.
A mutual friend introduced us.
She said, "You two should be friends."
And the world changed
because we bonded over lots of things.
Life, the universe, everything.
Kids the same age.
We live in the same part of London.
You know, we like
high heels and sequined dresses,
whatever, but primarily,
"where are all the women"
became the theme.
Right.
And if we were going to set up a business
that combined purpose with profit
as my fourth business
that's going to get me out of bed
in the morning,
the one topic that I care about
more than anything
is driving gender equality
and changing the world of work for women.
Not just entrepreneurs,
but every woman.
Because it has not changed fast enough.
And so, that's what AllBright's about.
It's called AllBright
after the Madeleine quote is,
"There's a special place in hell
for women who don't help other women."
So, our hypothesis is this,
that if women have better networks,
if they can upscale,
if they can access capital,
if they can build confidence
in resilience,
then we're going to change
the conversation for women at work.
So, it's a very ambitious protective.
We want to build
what we call amongst a global sisterhood
of smart minded ambitious women.
And there are two parts to the business.
Physical space,
which stands for something
above and beyond bricks and mortar
challenging at the moment.
Some open, some shut.
We've got buildings in the states,
buildings here.
And then what has been
a massive opportunity
and hopefully a huge support
during the pandemic
is our digital platform.
So, for anyone listening,
I'm afraid you do have
to be a woman to do this.
But go into the app store
and find the AllBright digital app.
And it's a page product.
But you get two weeks for free
and then it's $120 a year.
There's tons
of upscaling content in there.
And Anna and I wrote a book
called "Believe. Build. Become.:
How to Supercharge Your Career".
That was out last year,
which you should also check out.
And a lot of the content's on that.
Right?
So, everything.
How to negotiate a pay rise,
how to deal with imposter syndrome,
Amazing.
Loads and loads
and loads of women teaching.
And then there's a community.
And that's really important.
So, it's LinkedIn me
as Masterclass for women, if you like.
The community got loads of groups.
It's incredibly active.
And we have something called
sisterhood matching,
which is like online dating
for career women.
Amazing.
Match you up with other women
around the world
with similar interest backgrounds,
objectives.
So, it's an incredibly vibrant community.
Bigger, better than ever
because of the pandemic.
And I would encourage
all of the women listening to this
to check out AllBright Digital
and also check out our book,
which is very practical.
So, at the end of every chapter,
we met, you work.
There's a lot of exercises
you got to practice, practice, practice.
And that's one of our key messages
that it doesn't just happen
that you have to work at this.
For Anna and I,
even though it all looks
effortless every game,
everything from,
you know, dresses to delivery.
And we would encourage other women
to feel like they can do the same.
Debbie, I love that.
Thank you for the inspiration.
By the way,
that's exactly also the point that I,
that's important for me
to address in this show.
You remember one of the first question
that I asked was,
what are some mistakes
you've made with Love Home Swap.
Because I think that's just such
an integral part of every journey.
And sometimes we forget
when we look at
these incredible success stories,
that every success
comes after a multitude of failures
in small, perhaps failures
but leading up to that,
to those aha moments
that at the end seem so linear
with a narrative.
But like you said,
it's much easier looking
backwards than forwards.
Debbie, before we finish,
I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
And I'd love to ask
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use
to describe yourself.
Gosh. I would say determined, tenacious,
and on a good day, hopefully fun.
Debbie, thank you very, very much.
Best of luck with the
dark, cold London right now.
And I can't wait
to share this with the world.
Thank you.
Okay. Thanks a lot.